here's a liver King from you're saying
from his yeah so he's this nice guy he
he he's he pedals supplements he lies
he's probably on the roids he talks
about masculinity watching on the shirt
off that guy is an [ __ ] wait he's an
[ __ ] because he's just because he's
just a phony he's a fraud like he's just
he's a clown and like we all sit there
and like in 2022 the day of social media
and Tick Tock we're all like oh the
liver King let's let's put this [ __ ]
up on a pedestal that guy is no
different than a [ __ ] beta male woman
no [ __ ] different my Molly caveat
with that is so his his message is right
is to eat healthy live like the caveman
do so if he's promoting health I don't
give a [ __ ] how famous but again I will
say he does say a lot of good [ __ ] about
eating eating clean yeah I'll give that
so his main message is eating clean
living like the caveman did right I
don't give a [ __ ] if he's on stero I
don't do I don't give a [ __ ] but again
it's just like it's a gimmick dude it's
the [ __ ] gimmick like we live in a
world with [ __ ] gimmicks just